>> Laura: THE SHOOTING LASTED
SIX MINUTES BEFORE THE KILLER
FLED THE SCENE.
THAT DEPUTY HAS NOW RESIGNED.
A HIGH SCHOOL JUNIOR SURVIVED
AND THEY ATTENDED THE LISTENING
SESSION AT THE WHITE HOUSE.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
I KNOW HOW DIFFICULT THIS
SITUATION HAS BEEN THOUGH WE
CAN'T REALLY UNDERSTAND IT AND
WHAT YOU'VE ALL GONE THROUGH.
YOU WERE AMAZINGLY POISED
YESTERDAY,ARIANA AT THE WHITE
HOUSE EVENT.
I WATCHED EVERY MINUTE OF IT AND
I KNOW THE COUNTRY IS RALLYING
AND YOUR REACTION TO THIS NEWS
THAT WE JUST LEARNED A FEW HOURS
AGO ABOUT HOW THE SECURITY
DETAIL WHO HAD A WEAPON, DIDN'T
ENTER THE BUILDING.
YOU'RE REACTION TO THAT?
>> WELL, AS A FATHER AND THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US, IT'S
MADDENING TO HEAR THAT NEWS.
WHEN YOU PUT YOUR FAITH IN THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT TO ACT AND
PROTECT YOUR CHILDREN AND THEN
THEY FAIL TO ACT, IT'S JUST
INEXCUSABLE.
IT HIGHLIGHTS THE OTHER FAILURES
THAT LED TO THIS TRAGEDY AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE TRAGEDY WHICH
IS THE BREAKDOWN AT THE FBI AND
FAILING TO ACT ON THE TIPS AND I
THINK PEOPLE NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS DEPUTY'S APPARENTLY BEEN
HELD ACCOUNTABLE BUT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT WHO FAILED
TO ACT IN THIS CIRCUMSTANCE.
>> Laura: ALSO IN THE
INVESTIGATION THEY FOUND OUT THE
SECURITY CAMERA FOOTAGE THAT I
GUESS THE OFFICIALS ON THE SCENE
AT THE TIME WERE REVIEWING, WAS
DELAYED.
SO THEY WEREN'T GETTING
REAL-TIME INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
WAS HAPPENING INSIDE THE
BUILDING.
THERE WAS A SEVERAL MINUTE DELAY
SO THEY WERE REACTING TO THINGS
THAT ALREADY HAPPENED WHICH KIND
OF DEFEAT THE PURPOSE, DON'T YOU
THINK?
ARIANNA YOUR REACTION.
>> I THINK IT'S DISGUSTING A
POLICE OFFICER WAS ON CAMPUS AND
KNEW HIS JOB AND FOR HIM NOT TO
ENTER THE BUILDING WHERE
INNOCENT CHILDREN WERE BEING
SHOT IS DISGUSTING.
I THINK IN REGARDS TO THE
TECHNOLOGY DEPARTMENT AND THE
FACT THAT THE SECURITY FOOTAGE
WAS 20 MINUTES DELAYED SHOULD
NEVER HAVE HAPPENED.
THAT'S ONE OF THE SIMPLE ISSUES
EVERYONE CAN AGREE NEEDS TO BE
FIXED.
WE NEED TO BE PROACTIVE INSTEAD
OF REACTIVE.
WE CAN'T HAVE THE SECURITY
FOOTAGES BEING LOOKED AT AFTER
THE MATTER.
>> Laura: LAST NIGHT AT THE BIG
CNN EVENT THERE WERE A LOT OF
RAW EMOTIONS.
ONE STUDENT WHO WANTED TO ATTEND
BUT DIDN'T ATTEND BECAUSE HE WAS
UPSET TO HIM IT SEEMED LIKE HIS
QUESTION WAS BEING SCRIPTED FOR
HIM AND SPOKE TONIGHT ON
TUCKER'S SHOW.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THEY TOOK WHAT I HAD WROTE
AND WROTE THE QUESTION FOR ME.
>> BUT NOT WITH YOUR WORDS.
THEY PUT THEIR WORDS IN YOUR
QUESTION.
THAT SEEMS DISHONEST.
>> IT DEFINITELY DID AND WHY I
DIDN'T GO LAST NIGHT.
ORIGINALLY I THOUGHT IT WAS
GOING TO BE MORE OF MY OWN
QUESTION AND TURNED OUT TO BE
MORE OF JUST A SCRIPT AND SHE
SAID THAT OVER THE PHONE I NEED
TO STICK TO THE SCRIPT.
>> Laura: ARIANNA, WHAT'S YOUR
REACTION TO THAT?
CNN DENIES THIS, BY THE WAY, BUT
THEY HAVE A HISTORY OF PLANTING
QUESTIONS THAT MICHELLE MALKIN
AND OTHERS HAVE WRITTEN ABOUT
BEFORE AT OTHER EVENT.
BUT COLTON HOHN
BUT COLTON HOH
BUT COLTON HOBB
BUT COLTON HOBB W
BUT COLTON HOBB WHO
BUT COLTON HOBB WHO G
BUT COLTON HOBB WHO GAV
BUT COLTON HOBB WHO GAVE
BUT COLTON HOBB WHO GAVE T
BUT COLTON HOBB WHO GAVE THA
BUT COLTON HOBB WHO GAVE THAT
INTERVIEW WAS EMFATTIC
EMPHATIC ABOUT THAT POINT.
>> Laura: THE POINT OF THE
MEETING WAS TO HEAR THE KIDS AND
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN IS
INEXCUSABLE.
OUR VOICES NEED TO BE HEARD AND
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ASK
ANY QUESTION HE WANTED TO HAVE
BUT SOME NETWORKS DON'T WANT US
TO GIVE OUR REAL OPINIONS AND
WANT US TO FURTHER THEIR OWN
AGENDAS.
>> Laura: MOST OF THE STUDENTS,
ARIANNA, THAT'D SAME OPINION
WHAT TO DO TO BAN CERTAIN
WEAPONS AND TRASH THE NRA AND BE
REALLY DISRESPECTFUL TO MARCO
RUBIO AND THEY ALL SEEM TO BE IN
AGREEMENT AS FAR AS I COULD
TELL.
THERE WAS NO DIVERSITY OF
OPINION AMONG THE STUDENTS OR
ANYONE ELSE I SAW IN THE
AUDIENCE.
>> THAT'S NAT -- NOT SURPRISING
AT ALL.
I SPOKE TO AN CNN PRODUCER AND
HE INSINUATED THEY WERE LOOKING
FOR PEOPLE WILLING TO ESPOUSE A
CERTAIN NARRATIVE AND TAKING THE
TRAGEDY AND TURNING IT INTO A
GUN CONTROL DEBATE.
AND PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT GUN
CONTROL DON'T UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE
I'M A REPUBLICAN, I'M A GUN
OWNER.
I'M A RESPONSIBLE GUN OWNER AND
IT'S NOT ABOUT TAKING AWAY GUNS
FROM PEOPLE LIKE ME BUT KEEPING
THEM OUT OF THE HAND OF PEOPLE
WHO SHOULD NOT HAVE THEM OR
IRRESPONSIBLE OR A THREAT TO
SOCIETY.
LAST NIGHT WHEN TED DEUTSCHE
KEPT REPEATING HIS MANTRA IS
ALMOST EVERY GUN OUT THERE AND
THE ASSAULT WEAPONS WON'T
ACCOMPLISH ANYTHING ALONG THOSE
LINES.
I AGREE WE NEED TO MAKE HEADWAY
AND RAISE THE AGE TO BUY A
RIFLE, I AGREE WITH THE
PRESIDENT ON THAT, BUT BEYOND
THAT THE FOLKS YELLING GUN
CONTROL DON'T HAVE A GREAT GRASP
ON WHAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
>> Laura: SO THE CNN PRODUCER
WHO CALLED YOU RIGHT AFTER THE
SHOOTING SAID SPECIFICALLY WHAT
ABOUT THE WAY THEY WANTED TO
PRODUCE INTERVIEWS AND SO FORTH?
>> AS I RECALL, THE PRODUCER
SAID WE'RE LOOKING FOR PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
POLICY IMPLICATIONS ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED IN TERMS OF -- SHE
DIDN'T MENTION GUNS BUT IN TERMS
OF THE POLICY IMPLICATIONS FOR
PREVENTING FUTURE MASS SHOOTINGS
AND IF YOU KNOW FOLKS THAT WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THAT, WE'D LIKE TO
SPEAK TO THOSE PEOPLE.
>> Laura: VERY INTERESTING.
ARIANNA AND MR. KLEIN, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US.